I'm glad to see such a great crowd
today I'd like to
welcome Mr Spencer our guest
speaker our
city council Mayor John
haridan and I was also told to
uh acknowledge his father who's also a
member of our post but we haven't seen
him for quite some
time
relle council
member John
kosha I also want to welcome World War
II
vets Korean
veterans
Vietnam veterans Iraq veterans and
Afghanistan veterans also like to
welcome former
Chief it's been so long I only talked to
you five minutes
ago
Diaz Marilyn Diaz Marilyn Diaz thank you
boy bud and now I'd like to uh call
Duncan mcgilvery to present our next
speaker sier Madre VFW Post 3208 is
fortunate to have as guest speaker today
a globally renowned anti-terrorism
expert who has served all of the
National Security and Military agencies
of our government and as New York Times
best-selling author having written 13
books
the members of our post ask him to come
for two main reasons number
one as topic and experience are
consistent with the VFW Congressional
Charter which in section
23102 States as several of the purposes
to maintain true allegiance to the
government of the United States and
Fidelity to its Constitution and laws
Foster true patriotism maintain and
extend the instit tions of American
Freedom preserve and defend the United
States from all enemies number two again
consistent with our Charter to educate
the public on the current state of war
in which we are engaged and into which
we send our young men and women every
day to secure our country and its
citizens many of these soldiers Airmen
Sailors and Marines come home broken and
traumatized
we are celebrating these Warriors today
and those living still living who came
before them and thank them for their
sacrifice and service post 3208 is proud
to introduce Robert Spencer after Mr
Spencer speaks he will be available in
the Hart Park house for book signing of
his latest book Arab winter comes to
America I'm proud to introduce Mr
Spencer
thank you very much it's a great honor
for me to be here and to speak at a VFW
event a tremendous honor to be in the
presence of uh World War II veterans my
father was in the Navy in World War II
and uh of course the debt that we owe to
All Veterans can never be
understated uh the fact is that were it
not for our veterans of course we would
not be here today on this peaceful and
sunny and beautiful afternoon here in
Sierra Madre California or if we were we
would be here under vastly different and
far more difficult
circumstances and the fact is however
that we are despite this beautiful day
and the peaceful surroundings at War
today and yet this war is different from
World War 2 from Korea from Vietnam from
any war that the United States has ever
fought in the past
and it's different because so many years
after it is generally considered to have
begun on September 11th 2001 there is
still no agreement as to who exactly we
are fighting and how exactly to fight
them and this is an extraordinarily
strange
situation there is no
consensus as to what the people we are
fighting want and how we can achieve a
piece ful
future and times the disagreements are
very sharp for example alqaeda and Isis
or the Islamic State as it calls itself
now say that they are fighting in order
to undermine and ultimately destroy
every non-muslim government in the world
and every government ruled by Muslims
that does not follow Islamic law
strictly and
fully and they want to establish the
rule of Islamic law over the whole
world in response to that the president
of the United States the Secretary of
State the leaders of the opposition
party the rulers of Great Britain France
Germany everyone you can practically
name has said no you don't really mean
that you don't really stand for anything
Islamic at all the vast majority of
Muslims repudiate you and we stand with
them against you now that all sounds
great but in order to defeat an enemy
you have to understand that enemy you
have to know that enemy that's the first
rule of any successful
Warfare and so simply to wave away these
groups claims for example the Islamic
State's claim to be not only Islamic but
to be the perfect embodiment of Islamic
law simply to dismiss that as so many of
our leaders
have on in both
parties is to prend from a duty that we
have to understand at least what they
think they're doing and what they might
be going to do next we cannot possibly
answer these questions we cannot
possibly know how best to defeat them if
we don't understand their own motives
and
goals and for that you have to go into
Islam I brought here the Quran and the
Quran of course is the holy book of
Islam and this Quran has commentary so
that uh we don't have to be in doubt as
to what the passages actually mean
commentary by molana maudi say Abu Allah
maudi who was a Pakistani politician and
Scholar of Islam he died in
1979 and he's very mainstream he's not
an
extremist he was the founder of what is
a very major political party in Pakistan
to this day jamaat islami and he was an
Islamic scholar he wrote a multiv volume
commentary on the Quran of which this is
a one volume uh summary and I guarantee
you that if you go into I'm sure there
are Islamic bookstores in LA and if uh
uh you don't want to go into them then
you can go online to
islamicbookstore.com or islamicity.com
you will find maud's books and many of
them for sale he is internationally
renowned and respected he is a
mainstream scholar of Islam now if we
look at the Quran and what the Islamic
State says that they are doing in the
name of Islam one of the controversial
things that they have said is that they
are beheading people because this is an
Islamic imperative and there have been
many Muslims who have said oh no no no
that has nothing to do with Islam but
when we look at the Quran actually in
chap 47:4 it says when you meet the
unbelievers strike it their
necks when you meet the unbelievers
strike it their necks the Islamic State
they read that as well as anybody else
can another thing that the Islamic State
does that we have all heard about is
they have captured hundreds possibly
even over a
thousand women yazidi and Christian
women non-muslim women and they have
sold them off into sexual slavery now
this is a horrific thing and it's hard
to even imagine that this kind of thing
goes on in the world in the 21st century
but here again they point to the Quran
the Quran says in ch 4:3 if you fear
that you might not treat the orphans
justly then marry the women that seem
good to you two or three or four if you
fear that you will not be able to treat
them justly then marry only one or from
among those your right hands possess now
what is a woman who your right hand
possesses what does that mean let's ask
Mal Dudi the notable commentator on
Islam he says and he wrote I remind you
long before the Islamic State came on
the scene he said this expression
denotes slave girls I.E female captives
of War who are distributed by the state
among individuals when no exchange of
prisoners of War takes
place so here get again the Islamic
state is reading the Quran and acting
upon it another thing they have done is
in mosul which was a historically
Christian City or I should say a city
with a large Christian population in
Iraq a Christian population that went
back practically to the time of Christ a
very ancient Christian
population they went into mosul and they
marked the homes of the Christians with
a nun which is the Arabic letter N that
is the first word of nasara or nazarin
the quran's words for Christians they
marked them because they went back to
those homes and then demanded that the
Christians pay them money or convert to
Islam or they would be killed and a lot
of the Christians rejected this triple
choice and uh fled the area such that
the uh Archbishop the Catholic
Archbishop of mosul said that he he said
and I quote I have lost my d dasis to
Islam he didn't say I've lost my church
or my Parish or my faith community he
said I've lost my entire dasis every
Christian here is
gone and he warned that the same thing
was going to happen in Europe and
America if we were not aware of the
threat that we face in its full nature
and magnitude now when they went to do
this at the to the Christians they were
acting upon another passage of the Quran
chapter 9: 29 which says fight against
those who do not believe in Allah do not
obey Allah and his messenger and do not
forbid what he has forbidden even if
they are of the people of the book which
is the quran's term primarily for Jews
and Christians until they pay the gizia
which is a tax with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued and that
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued means in other words that they
submit denied basic rights they submit
as inferiors in the society under the
rule of Islamic law now this is what
maudi says about this passage the
purpose for which the Muslims are
required to fight you notice he says
required to fight it's not an option as
far as he's concerned is not as one
might think to compel the unbelievers
into embracing Islam so they're not
forcing conversions and that's
reassuring but unfortunately that's not
all he says he goes on to say rather its
purpose is to put an end to the suarin
the rule of the unbelievers so that the
latter are unable to rule over
people so that the latter the
unbelievers are unable to rule over
people he's saying no government that is
headed by non-muslims or does not follow
Islamic law has any legitimacy anywhere
in the world the authority to rule
should only be vested in those who
follow the true Faith unbelievers who do
not follow this true Faith which is of
course Islam should live in a state of
subordination
anybody who becomes convinced of the
truth of Islam May accept the faith of
his or her own valtion the unbelievers
are required to pay the gizia the pole
tax in return for the security provided
to them as the dees protected people of
the Islamic State protected people you
remember like the mafia you know you pay
protection and they don't break your
store Windows was like that gizia the
tax symbolizes the submission of the
Believers to the susany of Islam now
this is not my opinion this is not some
extremist fantastic Twisted hijacked
version of Islam this is a mainstream
commentator on the Quran who is
internationally famous who is
interpreting the passages of the Quran
in a way that is entirely consistent
with the way that the Islamic state has
been
behaving now obviously there is a
multiplicity of understanding ings in
Islamic Theology and law just as there
is among Jews and Christians the problem
is that to say that this has nothing to
do with Islam as the president and the
Secretary of State have said on numerous
occasions ignores the fact that this has
everything to do with Islam by the word
of Muslim authorities themselves and had
were time permitting I could give you
plenty more who said the same
thing the problem that we face is deeply
rooted within the Islamic religion and
yet is completely obscured
by all kinds of misinformation and
disinformation and even in people's
ordinary experience you know they say
well my friend Ahmed he's a very devout
Muslim and he's a wonderful guy so what
you're saying could not be
true obviously however we have to
understand that within Islam there is a
spectrum of belief knowledge and fervor
it's not as if because because these
things are taught in the Quran and
because many Muslims believe that this
gives them the responsibility to wage
war against and subjugate unbelievers
that that means every Muslim is going to
be doing it any more than you can say
that every Christian or every Jew or
every Buddhist or whatever does any
particular
thing however if it is a problem that is
rooted within Islamic Theology and law
then
clearly it has to be addressed as such
or no remedy is going to fix it for
example if the Islamic state is stamped
out and if we think that the Islamic
state is the only group that behaves
this way then we might think well then
the problem's solved we're done it's all
fixed now but if this is a larger
tradition within Islam if the Quran has
passages and there are plenty more that
I could read you men ating Warfare
against unbelievers then there are many
more Muslims besides those in the
Islamic State that will be wanting to
implement them such that even if the
Islamic state is gone tomorrow by some
miracle we'll still be facing the same
problem in other
manifestations I can give you another
example and that is the Muslim
Brotherhood the Muslim Brotherhood of
course you've all heard of they've been
around since the
1920s do you know that the Muslim
Brotherhood was founded in 1928 in Egypt
by Hassan Alana who was founding it in
order to restore the caliphate the
califate being the supernational Beyond
National Unity of the Muslims and the
foundation of the uh Islamic Allegiance
in the world transcending all national
or ethnic
allegiances and the caleff is considered
to be the successor of Muhammad as the
military political and spiritual leader
of the Muslims the Islamic State says
we've established the caliphate we've re
restored it it was abolished in 1924 by
the secular Turkish government the
Islamic State says they've re
reestablished it the Muslim Brotherhood
has been working since the 1920s to do
just that they had their best shot when
the uh Mubarak regime was toppled with
the enthusiastic uh support of the
United States and a Muslim Brotherhood
regime came to power but they so
disgusted the Egyptian people within a
year that they themselves were
toled but what is less known about this
is that the Muslim Brotherhood is
actually working for exactly the same
goals that the Islamic state is and
holds exactly the same beliefs and
exactly the same views of Islam they
have different methods by which they
want to go about it the Islamic State
will never say hey let's lay down our
arms and participate in elections in
Iraq and Syria they're never going to do
it the Muslim Brotherhood of course
participated in and won an election in
Egypt but this is just a difference of
method not of goal and not of overall
Outlook now bringing it all back home
the Muslim Brotherhood is deeply
embedded and very active in the United
States all and I say all without
exception of the leading Muslim groups
in the United States have demonstrable
links established by the justice
department to the Muslim
Brotherhood including the Council on
American Islamic relations the Islamic
Society of North America the Muslim
American society many many others
now the US government is in the very
strange and paradoxical position of
having declared that these
groups were involved with were connected
to the Muslim Brotherhood and an
internal document of the Muslim
Brotherhood was discovered during an FBI
raid on a Muslim Brotherhood connected
charity and the document outlined the
group grp strategic goals for the United
States and it's said and I quote the
brothers must understand that their work
in America is a kind of grand Jihad in
eliminating and destroying Western
Civilization from
within and sabotaging its miserable
house by their hands and the hands of
the Believers so that it falls and
Allah's religion is Victorious over
other religions now did you catch that
sabotaging its miserable house by their
hands whose hands the hands of the
miserable unbelievers that's
us they are going to use they were
saying in their strategic document for
the United States they're going to use
non-muslims in the United States to
undermine the United States freedoms our
political system the the the values and
the principles that were enumerated
earlier the freedom of speech the
equality of Rights of all people before
the law and so on and undermine all that
from
within now you look at the Muslim
Brotherhood linked organizations the
Council on American Islamic relations
the Muslim American society the Islamic
Society of North America in the first
place they're very well connected you
would think after the justice department
said these groups have links to the
terror group Hamas to the Muslim
Brotherhood that they would have cut off
all contact with them but my colleague
Pamela Geller and I did a uh Freedom of
Information Act request to the justice
department a couple years ago asking
them for records of all their
collaborations with the Islamic Society
of North America and the Council on
American Islamic relations we got a huge
box back of a thousand pages of
documents these guys are regularly in
and out of the justice department they
have tremendous influence there and and
power
there and that was just the first box
they said there's plenty more
coming the Muslim Brotherhood
organizations in the United States if
you look at their records the Council on
American Islamic relations in particular
they have opposed every counterterror
measure that ever was considered by
Congress by the Senate by the president
or by any local government or law
enforcement
organization they even protested against
and successfully ended a program in LA
right here to do a census of the local
mosques now if you wanted to do a census
of the ethnic makeup and the the the
numbers involved and so on of the local
churches the churches would open their
doors and show you all their records but
they wanted to do a census of the
mosques and see the the where the
mosques were and who how many people
went to each one and the ethnic makeup
in each one and so on and it was
considered bigoted and racist and
hateful and islamophobic and the deputy
mayor of Los Angeles at the time Arif
Ali Khan he got it
cancelled Arif Ali Khan was then named
by Barack Obama to a high position in
the Department of Homeland
Security so the problem here is that
when these groups have this influence
and they are linked to this the Muslim
Brotherhood organization which is on
record saying that they are working
towards sabotaging the United States
from within it is extremely foolish and
shortsighted of our elected officials or
government officials or law enforcement
officials to have anything to do with
them
nonetheless they are completely in
completely mainstream completely
accepted and as was noted in the
introduction I myself have uh I spent
about five years uh training the US Army
US Army Central Command uh various Army
groups military groups the FBI the CIA
and others I would from time to time go
and give them training so they would
understand the belief system of the
enemy not the bad guys the enemy that's
what they used to say in real wars and
they would be able to counter it and
this was all stopped at the behest of
these very same Muslim Brotherhood
groups who in 2010 they wrote to the
president and they wrote to the uh at
that time John Brennan was in the
Department of Homeland Security and now
of course he's the head of the CIA and
they demanded that I by name be
dismissed and that other trainers like
me be dismissed and that every
counterterror training program and all
counterterror training materials be
purged of any mention of Islam and Jihad
in connection with terrorism
now this is a recipe for disaster this
is not about me personally if we do
don't not if we are not able to or Bound
by political considerations not to speak
about what the enemy is all about we
will never be able to understand him and
never be able to defeat
him and so I hope in conclusion that uh
as we Mark another Veterans Day coming
up and as we are here at this observance
now we will dedicate our everyone here
to cutting away cutting through this
disinformation and
misinformation and recovering some of
the realism that characterized the wars
that America fought in the past when we
weren't afraid to say the Nazis were
evil and obviously in this case we're
not saying all Muslims are evil but
obviously these jihadis who are
enslaving and raping and killing and
justifying it by their holy book yes
that is evil and it does no good to
anyone to dissemble about it this
willful ignorance is going to be the end
of the freedoms for which our veterans
have fought and which they secured and
saved for us if we don't turn it around
and turn it around quickly thank you
very
much
thank
you he's going to be available at the
Hard house for questions so if you after
we're completed you can go in there and
he'll be there for any questions you
might want to talk and continue speaking
with him
once again I'd like to thank you for his
speech thank congresswoman Judy Chu
thank all the world war in fact could
all the World War II veterans stand up
so we can give them an
Applause we have any Korean veterans
stand
up Vietnam veterans please stand up
Iraq Afghanistan
veterans once again thank you to all of
you with this I'd like to have V back
here to sing the final
song After the song we will retire to
the heart house you can continue
speaking uh to uh Mr Spencer and we have
ref frenchs there
aming
Grace how
sweet the
sound that say
a like
me
was was lost but now I am found was
blind but now I
see to was Grace that Tau My Heart To
Fear and Grace my fear
Rel how pra
just it that Grace
appear the hour I first
belied through
many
ders toys and
snares I have
already de
come was was Grace that
brought me save th far and Grace will
lead me
home when we've been there
10,000 years bright
shining as the
sun we
know St to
sing God's grace that when we first
be we
know days to sing God praise than when
we first
be
once again thank you for all coming and
like I said uh you're all welcome to the
heart house where we have refreshments
and you can uh continue speaking with uh
Mr Spencer thank you thank
you right
didn't want didn't want to
interrup
he was originally in Los
Angeles
he I was talking to
Angie yeah go
ask
n
the